hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to IRA now this is IRA act
one of what I can only assume to be an
episodic type game that's about
something I don't know once again I'm
going into this blind the current IRA
demo contains pre-alpha gameplay but all
I know it's another highly rated indie
game and I'm always happy to play these
types of game but this one seems more of
a story-driven type game the smell of
rocket fuel hangs in the air even this
far outside of town
the year is 1932 and summer fades over
the land surrounding pilgrimage has
launched a fast approaches what were
they launching in 1932 anticipation
fills the air in the world's gaze is
drawn to the tiny town as final trains
make their way into the station good
evening listen to elder's news radio
where the words are as true as they are
fresh I'm Cody copper and I'll be your
host tonight the town is abuzz who wants
the holocene only weeks away and
children's once again be thrust into
world spotlight first first inner Shaw
hustle depart from the pilgrimage wand
Center traversing the boy to finish our
space in order to explore the mysteries
of the mythic system don't forget to
pick up your viewing tickets for the
launch and ID if you left if you have
the pocketbook in other news the Martian
mining season is once again upon us and
many listeners have noticed the influx
of seasonal workers in town
that the world is watching some peas
let's all be on our best behavior and
save the wheeldin ISM and allow housing
for the minds no meaning incident okay
that's bizarre why are they so worried
about the press also why are people on
Mars also why is it 1932 and we're going
to interstellar space here and also why
is pilgrimage with you supposedly a
small town that they've been sup talking
about the Center for all hello well
looks like it'll just be you and me
riding the rest of this line pal oh oh I
get choices um let's see why what's the
next town next up line is pilgrimage
last town 450 miles that's like you and
me ought to be steering clear there
about now see um
what's wrong with pilgrimage oh you're
not gonna find any work there that's for
sure not unless you plan on hauling it
up to Mars and Teleco owns that town
between the miners headed for Mars and
the holocene it doesn't seem like the
kind of place I'd like to get caught up
last ride out to Mars leave soon so
miners are crawling all over that town I
know work scarce some damn to be
desperate enough to sell your soul to in
Teleco and go mine in the red sand or
bastards
nobody will even notice him everyone's
got their eyes on the holocene
all those rich folks heading into town
from launch day Teleco we'll be sure to
keep types like us out of the way it's
all just profit for an Teleco they don't
care who has to suffer to make a buck
Oh God pilgrimage gateway to the stars
gateway to nothing if you asked me the
whole thing's a sham folks there are as
poor as anyone else
Osho if you're living in that town then
Intelli Koch good as ohms nope there's
nothing for us there in pilgrimage that
town is a dead end that's crazy
mammy did so much world building and I
know it was exposition but even so I am
like fascinated by what's going on here
and I don't even know what's going on
here why this in Teleco own a town and
what's the importance of pilgrimage to
the ability to go to the Stars like why
this small town just to make much sense
to me but then again what do I know
still miles from town a tiny farmhouse
sits alone amongst the fields a place a
young boy named IRA calls home IRA hi
there I didn't hear you come in oh is
that me am i IRA am i this IRA fella I'm
just finishing up the car here did you
need something mom told me to come out
is there anything I can do to help
because I don't remember mom even
talking to me Oh Thank You IRA sure I
could always use an extra hand I'll just
try to get the car back up and running
before I run out of time here also why
why is like the technology of everything
else like to the period but man before I
leave I mean I can't leave you and your
mother here all winter with the car
breaking down every couple of miles see
aren't you excited to go to Mars again
well no it's not like that IRA it's hard
work and just feels very far from home
it isn't nearly as glamorous as all that
Holocene business going on I know you're
interested in all that all the buzz
around the ship had to do a new star but
mining on Mars it's just work at least
the car will be in good shape before I
go get to bring me that wrench from the
workbench okay I got it dad I'm getting
it I'm hell
Bing yeah I almost grabbed it oh I got
it okay man that's weird
hello what's with my eyes - looks like I
just have two buttons for eyes yeah just
a few turns here all right now I just
need a fuel line to replace this one
here I think there's one out in the barn
could you run out and see if you can
find it you got a dad um I'll go get
that goodbye the night air was crisp but
cool wind moving in from the north
catching up the last of summers worth
it's better be the way to the barn I
think I may have screwed up Hey look I
gotta go to the barn any minute now
gonna get there someday hey minna no it
would have been directions on which way
to go but yeah this is just so
fascinating like I have so many
questions and also it's beautifully made
I mean the animations are janky but
there's obviously just a demo for what
they got here then the side-scrolling
elements of it it reminds me of you know
inside which I just played but that's
just because the side-scrolling elements
of it are probably similar the darkness
in the barn is thick but moonbeams
through the cracks give just enough
light to illuminate a few boxes tucked
in the corner something shifts in the
upper loft but it's out of you and
concealed by shadows see call up there
hello
[Music]
IRA's voice has swallowed up by the
darkness there is no response
eirick climbs the sheer ladder to the
upper loft and peers over its edge the
moonlight quickly falls off to blackness
and nothing can be made out search the
loft
this seems like a bad idea but I'm gonna
do it anyway iris steps into the silent
darkness but even from this closer
Vantage nothing can be seen memory tells
him he must be near the far wall but the
feeling is that of standing in abyss
feel right yeah feel around there feel
the monsters teeth iris hands meet with
a metal surface smooth and cold the
object is large taller than he can reach
and far too wide to put his arms around
it is sturdy and finely crafted unlike
anything else on a farmer that IRS ever
experienced I'm just caressing the metal
breasts of a cyborg that's what I'm
doing
iris and continued to probe the object
knee makes contact with glass like a
small window looking out from this
strange vessel he lays his bomb upon the
glass and the startling feeling of
nearness to another person falls over
IRA he recoils at the sensation all of
the seemingly impossible but in this
darkness reason has little place IRA
makes his way back down the ladder
unsure of what he had found
and his fear subsided as he distanced
himself from the device okay then I
guess I'm just gonna look for a fuel
line he tosses aside old soaked rags and
his fingers quickly find the soft rubber
hose IRA tugs firmly but it's lodged
between some rust bits of junk and won't
come free he pulls again harder this
time but the hose is lodged tightly with
one final heave the hose come free but
knocks a box to the ground and sends its
contents bouncing into the darkness
I'm being an old radio conceal by the
shadows on the wall jostling with left
okay that's creepy
IRA look surround the darkness of the
barn and it's overcome with a feeling of
unwelcome --mess he hurries out the door
hose in hand yeah no joke yeah if I felt
a smooth metal breast in the darkness
and then heard the haunting sounds of
that goddamn radio I'd be a little
concerned too so we're just not gonna
talk about that we're not gonna I'm
curious to go back though I'm I am
curious to see if there's anything new I
have the hose now I don't want to go
back in there not in this darkness
anyway
oh sure you're a little [ __ ] babies
that well I'm getting here your little
cowardly [ __ ] baby can't gather up the
courage to go in darkness and feel up
some metal boobs huh Oh little baby
it'll be okay someday you'll be brave
all right dad I got I got I got a rubber
hose and I made it to first base with a
toaster it was awesome anyway here you
go ah this damn thing
what oh the hose right here on a second
the damn threads are stripped again
cheap and Teleco trash they make this
garbage to last about a month I swear
biggest company in the world so the
bastards think they can do whatever the
hell they want
send us off to sweat and bleed on Mars
for next to nothing if it wasn't for the
Union bad as things are now before the
Union we'd have a death every day
still most of us can barely afford to
buy gear that isn't about to fall apart
can you believe that
remind them we mined for them up on that
godforsaken planet and we have to buy
our own gear
it's a miracle we don't all die up there
it's still a lot of us do that's sad
a lot of good men don't come back there
too many widows in this town because of
that damn company this isn't a good this
isn't very reassuring dad son of a [ __ ]
this is all gone to hell now let's see
are you upset because mom is getting
sicker oh man we're going into the dark
levels of exposition now dot dot dot i
well i cant its fine IRA everything's
gonna be fine I just can't think about
that now right now we're gonna be all
right
all of us why don't you head in your
mother might need a hand with dinner I
think they're doing a special about the
hallow scenes not on TV you don't want
to miss that right go on inside IRA I
just need to spend some more time here
getting this back together see oh I'm
sorry no it's not like that IRA it's not
you at all it's just everything else I
love you son
I'll see you inside in a bit okay oh
that's so sad oh so sad god man is
horrifying the buyer on equipment could
barely trust the guard the government's
equipment that they'd give me my god I
wouldn't buy my own no actually wait
does this backwards I would definitely
buy my own but if I didn't have the
money for it I'd be screwed
let me just wander in to mom and dad's
room squeak hello IRA
I didn't know you were asleep that's all
right IRA not quite sleeping just tired
I was gonna watch that special on the
holocene with you remember I just give
me a few minutes I need to wake myself
up everything okay
of course everything's fine IRA this has
been a hard week with your father
getting ready to leave and all it's
nothing for you to worry about why don't
you go watch you're special you can tell
us all about it at dinner oh I never did
start good dinner cooking could you go
and do that for me
all you have to do is put the pot on the
stove everything is made after you do
that you can go and get your father so
we can all eat okay I'll put one on
dinner that would be lovely and so sad
Thank You IRA see out there soon I love
you oh so sad why is she sick why does
that have to leave why is world the way
that world is man I gotta admit like you
know graphically it's not terribly
interesting right now but like the story
in like the environment you know the the
world that they're building already it's
just really fascinating like
legitimately it's it's honestly
fascinating because everywhere I look
technology is exactly as it was back in
the day maybe a little bit ahead but
even so for a spacefaring civilization
that has workers unions on Mars that's
interesting medical oh no
the medical terminology was too foreign
to four IRA to make any sense of it but
he could read his parents faces when
they returned to the doctor with these
scraps of paper the words were
meaningless the only option was to wait
oh that's
I mean if I had to guess it's probably
cancer but even so go to IRAs room I
should probably go get dad but I want to
make sure everything here is ok
join now it's nothing in here to even
look at go to Hall no there was nothing
well he's in the holocene and the
Martian union that's that's the interest
that every growing lad should have in
the heartland of what I can only assume
is maybe America
oh well that's disconcerting look wait
whoa where's what Hey Monza's gone
what the hell's going on here okay oh oh
the sound of water floods the sense is
washing away an old reality leaving
behind only the shell of Irish form or
life memories wring out like echoes
fading in a slow procession of years
gone by
[Music]
what the past decays in the future
remains unseen time pressing forward
blindly unaware of its mortal passengers
[Music]
the flow of hours turning into decades
caries IRA down it's twisting streams
[Music]
it carries his father to distant Martian
mines
[Music]
it sweeps up his mother his home and his
bearing all there's a grave oh no oh no
oh no and it carries ira to places he is
never known oh no oh what is happening
ira finds what he feels like stability
washing ashore on the rigidness of a
moment lost and alone but a voice rises
from within it draws him back into the
house like a sign of hope through the
murkiness of this reality does it I
don't know if it does like what was with
the cyborgs whatever in the barn
who is that about what is all of this oh
god it's empty the call grows louder
guiding IRA through tomb of something I
didn't finish that Oh God
Oh that's scary but let me go check here
first I know you're eager beaver to go
in there but I want to see if my room's
available it is I bet this is depressing
oh good what the hell is on the walls
what's with the symbols what is that
aliens aliens maybe I don't know why is
the refrigerator gone why'd they put a
cloth of their grandfather okay
don't I go the inner voice is clear now
drawers IRAs up the stairs promising
escape does it okay a familiar feeling
comes with the Attic stale air but it is
fleeting Oh God
oh that's obsession I know about
obsession that looks like a lot of
obsession
okay
lithic Smiths
a distant voice rises through the radio
static its tone familiar but the words
to muffled to make out the sound is
barely audible the buyer finds comfort
in the noise between fost attic closing
his eyes IRA focuses on the force world
words reveal themselves how can we know
where we've been see what I've been
nowhere only by looking backwards here
is everywhere where there's no point in
looking backwards and here is everywhere
it sounds like some profound [ __ ] so
I'll say that it is where we have all
come from that much is true
but knowing what has been is not knowing
at home do you know where you will be
nothing is certain no way is said
there's only one path I can only go
where I've been before no bottom is out
true there's never one path so nothing
is certain your perspective is flawed
but you must know that
hey how about screw you you wouldn't
have come otherwise you couldn't have
come
do you know where you are now of course
you couldn't know could you I'm this way
no I don't know I have no idea
wake up I'm not asleep it's not all a
dream I fell asleep in that bowl okay
we've reached a new level of weird ah
it's the symbols that were in my room
that's for sure
well I doesn't look good is it a time
machine okey-dokey then
[Music]
ah
IRA's mine slips through the years
escaping time caught up in the void but
the mind re-emerges called back into the
slow march of time after years of
suspension oh it was like a freezing
tube and he must have went on that trip
to the other stars IRAs head throbs with
pain he can barely focus on a single
thought the room is familiar but its
distant memory his mind is unable to
recall why he knows the place when he's
been here
really okay oh that's why it was all a
dream
IRA looks back at his abandoned pod the
strange cocoon from which he had
murdered okay so to catch you all up in
case you guys got lost because it could
be easy there's no memory of entering
the stasis but still carries the chill
of his revival his mind is clouded and
confused he went on that trip to space
to see all the other stars and explore
the lithic system which I don't know
what that is but they're exploring the
lithic system and he went on that
because he must have lost his mother and
then I bet his dad died on Mars so he
found no other purpose than to go to the
Stars the other pods in the room
remained sealed but her powered down and
lifeless the weight of loneliness sits
heavy over IRA so as everyone else dead
are they still frozen that seems bad in
his lysing power-up sequence era
detected attempting bypass of faulty
systems method failed please contact
administrator the elevators power
returns a crack of switch from above
life returning to the terminals dusty
speaker a voice emerges through the
static these rats again destroying my
ship wire by wire back vermin flee from
the sound of my voice
I just repaired this unit you miserable
rodents although this is the first time
the rats have powered up any system that
is fascinating computer log record event
on arrival at a lithic system plus 108 -
rats of transition from wire chewing to
attempt shtetl utilizing ship systems
motivation onion see see where am I
what's happening hello is there someone
down there you're not a rat at all the
ship's logs show that all the stasis
pods gave out ages ago
it's a miracle the crew is not dead
please excuse my informality allow me to
introduce myself this is your acting
captain assume commander of the holocene
- the master of this vessel it's good to
have you in my service it's good to have
anyone in my service actually
see how can I get out of here slow down
now attempt to remain calm crewman
you're perfectly safe there's no need to
panic you may be experiencing side
effects from stasis are you feeling ill
how would you describe your current
condition let's see I feel like I've
been hit by truck hmm I don't have any
records on the sensation of being hit by
a truck but it is good that you are
holding on to memories of Earth
nostalgia is a powerful antipsychotic
we'll keep a close monitor on your
status please feel free to report any
feelings of nausea increased heart rate
hallucinations or the sensation of death
given our situation I'm clearing you for
duty congratulations you'll have some
catching up to do especially after the
incident but I'm sure you'll rise to the
occasion what incident
I asked the Deo day one of a rival to
the lithic system the ship's automated
systems were compromised the system is
flooded with an electromagnetic
interference which reached havoc on the
electrical grid by the time I assumed
the role of Captain the stasis chambers
had succumbed to the surge but the ship
was saved I took control and navigation
manually just in time to our mission
shall continue we may be delayed by the
inconvenient mass loss of life among the
crew but you're here now you are
undoubtedly in a great state of
confusion allow me to reacquaint you
with the holocene - so the holocene one
was the first ship in his childhood is
the holocene - the second mission as you
can see stasis pods will not be in short
supply but they're filled with dead
bodies
documents oh the documents will need
removal okay I was completely right
there they're filled with dead bodies I
can't imagine that will be a pleasant
task yes yeah at least we'll be making
good use of the airlock ha ha ha
that was my humor programming because
I'm pretty sure I'm a robot ah good good
to see hydroponics is doing well your
stress will melt away as you watch the
fruits of your labor grow and propagate
good I think is this where all the rats
came from I don't know why there are
rats on the holocene but oh well
speaking of which you've been promoted
to head botanist what with the recent
loss of the entire biology department
good luck I mean congratulations don't
be intimidated by the state of the place
I trust you'll be able to get things in
good order in no time I would suggest
making it a priority though most of the
food stores were vented into space four
weeks ago see are you saying that
everyone on the ship is dead yes oh wait
yes
moving along ha ha ha ok
loneliness is exactly what you've always
wanted right the crushing isolation of
life in space with a robot companion who
could ask for more science
welcome to the laboratory level this is
a research vessel after all
state-of-the-art equipment should make
light work of uncovering the many
secrets of the lithic system I can't
seem to locate your scientific
background in your file but no matter
take some time to familiarize yourself
with the lab make yourself comfortable
and you should be ready to assume the
position have had to research her
congratulations again Oh
though I really must insist you dump her
to the touch the particle accelerator
before reading the manual even then
don't touch it are you showing this to
me don't worry about taking it all in at
once I have several volumes a system
manual somewhere you'll get there
eventually to the next level
Oh ah my pride and joy the heart of the
ship the engines core and my disposal
here's the power to bridge the Stars to
travel vast distances at great speeds to
conquer expanses the power would corrupt
the mind of a lesser captain but I
assure you you're in good hands of which
I have none because I'm a robot just
look at it take its Austral writing
potential there's actually several pay
grades above your clearance level why am
i allowing you to see this as your
captain i order you to erase your
memories of this place do you even know
what you're saying of course our journey
is nearing its and you're about to reach
the upper deck of the holocene - ah yes
it's me
hello I am your captain a robot this is
the 1080 second day in orbit of Hermes
on the outer rim of the lithic system is
our designated rendezvous point with the
crew of the holocene one protocol
dictates we awake da taking instructions
from the crew on the surface which has
yet to arrive probably because they're
all dead
let's see I already asked a question
what are you once again I'm the
commander of this vessel captain of the
Holocene - but I suppose that's not what
you mean I am z12 zero automated control
system for the housing - let's see
you're just a computer
what well yes that is true but I'm fully
capable of fulfilling my duties despite
my limited physical form
besides crew man with you here the
manifest has been doubled now our
mission is sure to succeed Oh
ki dokie then let's just have a
conversation
I gotta admit this is amazingly awesome
and interesting the limitations of what
you see in front of you are actually
being like countermanded by the story
itself which I'm totally on board with I
realize you're curious but please try
not to break anything
loading console systems communications
ah dead and the static sound emerges a
sound that was still ringing in the back
of its mind it flows through IRAs body
that interference has been flooding all
the standard radio channels since we
arrived has made maintaining ship
controls something of a challenge
the worst part has been maintaining a
stable orbit her sensors required
radical adjustments to make any sense of
navigation readouts it may also be what
killed everyone why do I know this sound
you must be mistaken it's quite
impossible for you to have heard the Sun
it is localized to the lithic system and
you only just woke from stasis perhaps
you're not hearing the signal clearly
allow me to amplify the receiver and
blow out your eardrums Oh or blow up the
entire ship
Oh God the interference caused another
power surge life support system gone
critical you need to evacuate the ladder
craft through the starboard hatch one
Lander reading is functional I should be
able access these doors oh it's time
atmosphere confounded any moment okay
goodbye I'm gonna run hey caboose key
I'm accessing the door controls no those
there
their doors open run and such
did we make it we might have made it we
might have made it that doesn't look
like a blow or gay here we go then this
is the beginning of subnautica the
system's interference is blocking
planetary transmission I'm scanning the
surface for signs of settlements well
that's a happiness along we're sending
too fast well we probably should just
grease our speeds here I'm gonna do that
by firing or rockets brace for impact
that laughing or coughing could be
Freddy laughing in the distance Oh No
alrighty then what have you got for me
bring it on I'm ready to face any
challenge oh it's a radio tower oh no oh
you can't end it there
oh no oh no I'm so into it I was so into
it oh god it was hitting all my buttons
the space button the mystery button the
slightly scary button the IRA button oh
no oh it's on Kickstarter man I gotta
support this one you guys don't have to
but I got to support this one that was
super uber cool that was super duper
cool I love that a lot like I mentioned
while I was playing at the limitations
of the graphics and the animation but
just the fact that the story was so
captivating even though it was filled
with exposition yes but you got to
establish it somehow and this is the
easiest way to do it
so still oh oh yeah sassy robot captain
Oh lost child whose parents are dead Oh
mystery of the lithic system I want to
know I want to know it all that was
really cool
so either way that is IRA act one if
this game gets kick-started and gets
released in full I want to see so much
of it I think it would benefit with a
little more polish on the graphical side
of things it was going for like a it had
a bit of a limbo vibe you know inside
vibe I think it could work with being
developed in that way but not in the
same like game obviously but just in
that style of side-scroller the
flexibility of Moomin and all that so
this could be really cool so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know we thigh this down in the comments
below and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]